let us now conclude with a fun problem
which is also a little bit of a puzzle
we are told that the king comes from a
family of two children what is the
probability that he's sibling it's
female well the problem is to loosely
stated so we need to start by making
some assumptions first let us assume
that we are dealing with an
anachronistic Kingdom where boys have
presidents in other words if the royal
family has two children one of which is
a boy and one is a girl it is always the
boy who becomes king even if the girl
who was born first let us also assume
that when a child is born it has 50%
probability of being a boy and 50%
probability of being a girl
and in addition let's assume that
different children are independent as
far as their gender is concerned okay
given these assumptions
perhaps we can argue as follows the
king's sibling is a child which is
independent from the king its gender is
independent from the Kings turn gender
so it's going to be a girl with
probability 1/2 and so this is one
possible answer to this problem is this
a correct answer well let's see we have
to make a more precise model so let's go
ahead with it we have two children so
there are four possible outcomes boy boy
boy girl girl boy and girl girl each one
of these outcomes has probability 1/4
according to our assumptions for example
the probability of a boy followed by a
boy is 1/2 times 1/2 we're we're also
using independence so each one of these
4
outcomes has the same probability 1/4
now we know that there is a king so
there must be at least one boy given
this information one of the outcomes
becomes impossible namely the outcome
girl girl and were restricted to a
smaller universe with only three
possible outcomes our new universe is
this green universe which includes all
outcomes that have at least one boy so
that we can catch a king we should
therefore use the conditional
probabilities that are appropriate to
this new universe since these three
outcomes inside the green set have equal
and conditional probabilities they
should also have equal conditional
probabilities so each one of these three
outcomes should have a conditional
probability equal to one-third in two of
these outcomes the sibling is a girl and
therefore the conditional probability
given that there is a king and therefore
given that there is a boy the
conditional probability is going to be
2/3 so this is actually the official
answer to this problem and this answer
is incorrect are we satisfied with this
answer maybe yes maybe no actually some
more assumptions are needed in order to
say that 2/3 is the correct answer let
me state what these assumptions are we
assume that the royal family decided to
have exactly two children so the number
two that we have here is not random it
was something that was predetermined
once they decided to have the two
children they had them at least one
turned out to be a boy and that boy
became a king
under this situation indeed the
probability that the sibling of the king
is female is 2/3
but these assumptions that I just stated
are not the only possible ones
let's consider some alternative
assumptions for example suppose that the
royal family operated as follows they
decided to have children until they get
one boy what does this tell us well
since they had two children this tells
us something that the first child was a
girl so in this case the probability
that the King sibling is a girl is equal
to 1 the only reason why they had two
children was because the first was a
girl and then the second was a boy
suppose that the royal family made some
different choices they decided to have
children until they would get two boys
just to be sure that the line of
succession was secured in this case if
we are told that there are only two
children this means that there were
exactly two boys because each one of the
two children was a girl the royal family
would have continued so in this
particular case the probability that the
sibling is a girl is equal to zero and
you can think of other scenarios as well
that might give you different answers so
2/3 is the official answer as long as we
make the precise assumptions that the
number of children the number 2 was
predetermined before anything else
happened the general moral from this
story is that when we deal with
situations that are described in words
somewhat vaguely we must be very careful
to state whatever assumptions are being
made and that needs to be done before we
are able to fake
a particular probabilistic model this
process of modeling will always be
something of an art in which judgment
calls will have to be made